you hear anything that says gala on it
if you drink like contact-lens fluid the
famed invite-only Met Gala is the place
to see the highest of high fashion worn
by the biggest stars but not every celeb
who's hit the red carpet has had a ball
it is such a jerk parade like you can
Tina Fey expressed her distaste for the
event to David Letterman after attending
in 2010 that's just every jerk from
every walk of life
Gwyneth Paltrow has attended the gala
several times before and after telling
USA Today the event was so unfun it was
boiling it was too crowded I did not
enjoy it at all
Amy Schumer did not hide her disdain for
the event in a 2016 interview with
Howard Stern I left earlier than I
should have been allowed but I mean it's
exciting you know it's like I got to
meet Beyonce right and she was like is
this your first and I was like it's my
last even so she attended the event
again the next year it's rude for
somebody to go to somebody's party and
then trash it I guess you know her so I
did write a tweet that kind of went
viral so I apologized to her and I said
you know jokes and whatever and she's
like oh you'll come next year and I was
like you know girl while speaking with
Schumer for her Lenny letter newsletter
Lena Dunham said of the night it was
like a crazy countdown to when we could
escape she came back in 2017 and 2018
Zayn Malik decided the Met wasn't for
him after hitting the carpet with
girlfriend Gigi Hadid in 2016
Zayn told GQ he'd rather be sitting at
home doing something productive than
dressing up in expensive clothes
and demi lovato called the 2016 Met Ball
a terrible experience in an interview
with billboard this one celebrity was a
complete and was miserable to be around
it was very cliquey
[Music]
[Applause]